hey luke here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and uh welcome to a
little v-log we're gonna do something a
little bit different this week i'm gonna
give you a little bit of a
behind-the-scenes peek at what it's like
to be a full-time youtuber and it is a
weird weird life but there's a lot of
things that go on behind the scenes that
you guys just don't see so i'm gonna
share a little bit of that um so first
off
this week i have been working on a
project that has been frustrating me
frustrating me for
over two years now on and off i have
been experimenting with primitive
fishing techniques and trying to figure
out how to use fishing gorges which is
a way that people used to make hooks
back in the old days
and i can catch bluegill and little
panfish with fishing gorges no problem
i've done several videos where i've just
rocked it i'm really good at it but i've
always wanted to catch a catfish or
bigger fish
on fishing gorges or homemade hooks or
that sort of thing so i have been
running around trying to find places to
buy cow bones to use to make bone
fishing gorges and fishing hooks and it
turns out petco is the place to do it so
anyway i'm gonna work on that
[Music]
it's gonna rain on me better take cover
five bone fish gouges i made them
different lengths so we can kind of
experiment and see which one works best
[Music]
[Applause]
little bone spearhead
there we go
all done
wow
that looks pretty serious
there we go my prototype bone spear
there was a beginning of my hook shape
but i dropped it off the forge and it
just broke hitting the ground
it was looking good until i dropped it
and then it broke
got to stop dropping these
there you go i got one bone hook that
i'd managed not to drop
there we go got the little gorge tied
onto a bit of braid all right should we
go get some worms yeah let's go look for
worms
all right that's the size of worm you
need oh look at this
we got a good uh 10 12 worms
we go in the black car yeah
all right so you need a piece of worm
that's about the same length as the
gouge and we're going to feed the gouge
inside the worm so the points just
barely stick out both sides that's what
it should look like when you baited it
oh there we go
there we go got one i had probably six
bites before i got one that actually
swallowed it and was able to land it oh
there we go
oh i didn't even get him in the throat
it's it's stuck underneath his lip
all right there's number two about six
worms in 30 minutes and i've landed
three bluegill
okay
far right ones just got a hit
something's grabbed my bait and swam off
a bit with it oh my reel just started
spinning
yeah
catfish is taking it
he dropped it maybe he'll come back for
it and swallow it who knows
oh the catfish took it went around the
corner and i as soon as i put tension on
he popped out and i was really get in
and a bass came up and hit it off the
surface
well we got some action but jacob wanted
to go home so we're gonna go home pick
this up again tomorrow all right it's
another day we're to have another crack
at this i'm going to try this fish hook
made from cowbone
well no bites can't test out our hooks
without some bites
guess we'll try it again another day all
right see you then well i ended up
spending about three nights trying to
catch catfish on a cow bone fish gorge
and got a couple good hits but no fish
landed so i'm just gonna save that film
footage for a later maybe one day i'll
be able to get a video made on that but
kind of ran out of time so i was gonna
go and try to spear a snake head with my
bone
fishing spear here
but it's been damaged a little bit
nathan got into my spear and was
throwing it across the yard and stabbing
rocks with it and so it is
it's a little busted plus i just don't
think the spear has the weight to really
penetrate a fish so i'm gonna go and
just shelve this project for later
and uh
yeah i'm gonna come back to this a
little bit later well the weather's
dropped about 30 degrees since i started
the fish gorge video so i'm gonna go
ahead and fire up the forge and i'm
gonna try to make a knife from an old
file i have laying around we're going to
see if we can't make a video out of that
[Applause]
well before we get started i got to fix
my tongs they are a little bit scampers
[Music]
so
the more you pound on your blade the
more squamous it can get and you lock it
into the bench vise and it helps
straighten it out a little bit nice
little cheap
[Applause]
there we go i'm happy with how that
turned out
well it's starting to get a little dark
and i want to go in and get some dinner
so we're going to put this up for right
now and i'm going to pick this up again
tomorrow morning
look at that that goes a long way making
it look like a real knife doesn't it
now that we have our knife the right
shape we need to harden it this is such
a fly by the seat of your pants process
it just
warped just ever so slightly
i think that worked this time now we're
gonna go and polish this up a little bit
[Applause]
here we go 320
all right we got some 800 grit
oh
i was sitting here putting the bevel on
and this edge caught in the belt sander
and it broke off and this knife went
flying up like 10 feet up in the air
came down and landed
right on the tip and broke the tip off
oh
it's frustrating but not surprising as i
was polishing it up i was starting to
see cracks in the steel you can see some
cracks right there and there
and they run all the way through the
blade i knew this thing was compromised
already i was just hoping i could get it
through long enough to actually show you
the whole process my guess is that when
i quenched it the steel was too hot and
it should have been a lighter color of
red
who knows though
yep
problematic
all right there's the days and a half
worth of work
oh guys i'm not gonna lie that knife
project really hurt i've i had to take a
little time and do some cleaning and
other things just to kind of get out my
mind over it so i organized my camping
gear
sleeping bags
winter sleeping bags more sleeping bags
that bin down there is just uh mres and
meals let's see we got cooking pots and
cooking utensils
seasonings
pocket knives fire starting stuff
utensils saws and axes more sleeping
bags
sleeping pads various tents more bags
and sleeping bags down there we've got
cots and chairs some more tents in there
luggage
lots of bags more bags more
backpacks
one project i've been working on lately
is getting tommy to start his own
youtube channel he's been talking
forever about wanting to do his own
videos and it's a great way for him to
earn money and save up for college in
the future and stuff so i've been kind
of encouraging him and he wants to do a
nerf war video
this is the aftermath so we need to get
him down here to clean that up here a
little bit daddy's not doing that one i
mean i was actually really proud of
tommy he actually started filming a
foraging video where we went harvesting
autumn olives and walnuts and other
things and he spent an entire day doing
that and
did a great job on it i actually got
that video done
so stay tuned i'm gonna announce it once
i post that one another thing i need to
do this week like i do every week is
video editing every time you guys see
about 20 minutes of footage that
represents an 8 to 10 hour day for me so
if we watch a 60 minute video that's at
least three days worth of editing on
really big videos like some of our
travel videos um that are like one to
two hours long some of those can take a
week and a half to edit about three
different videos in the hopper i need to
edit this week so i'm got about a good
day and a half of
two days worth of editing at least if
you guys ever want to know what i do
with my footage after i have done with
it i store it on external hard drives
these are five terabyte hard drives and
you can see how many i have just lying
around my computer is more over there
yeah so this one right here this one was
three months so five terabytes only
lasted me
um three months and i'm not filming high
quality footage this is 1080p with 30
frames per second i just film a lot a
lot a lot of footage
these laptops need a minimum of two
terabytes just to be able to handle
editing one video i mean these um
my laptops usually run three to four
thousand dollars and they last me about
a year or two so
well guys it has been a long week and me
and the family are just sitting here on
the couch watching a star wars movie you
guys having a good day yeah
but uh we guys hope you kind of enjoy
this little update a little behind the
scene sneak peek at everything going on
in our lives and uh and if you guys want
to see more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe
nailed it if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching